morning from glasgow i'm going to put
ashna under pressure because this
communique has literally just dropped
within the last few seconds as we're
bringing you uh the headlines here at
sky news is there anything you give us
at this stage or do you want me to come
back i can give you one
one point that is a positive so far so
what we were waiting for was the news
about the fossil fuel subsidies whether
that was remaining within the text so in
the last literally few seconds uh i can
read out that yes point 36 it is in
there uh countries need to accelerate
efforts towards the phase out of
unabated coal power and inefficient
fossil fuel subsidies recognizing the
need for support towards a just
transition i guess to greener future
economies that is significant because so
what does that mean so that means for
the first time in the united nations
document of this kind it looks as though
the fossil fuels and coal specific terms
remain within this document now it
survived the culling of a num of a
number of days now because they've been
going over this draft document over a
number of over a number of hours over
the last few hours but there was
pressure from countries like saudi
arabia to take that mention out or water
down that language even more we know
countries within the european union but
also other nations have been putting
pressure on them to make sure that
remains in the fact that that sticking
point of fossil fuel subsidies remains
within there is significant okay and
guessing australia had a view on that as
well um anna thomas people will be
joining us in just a second um who else
wanted it taken out uh countries like
australia countries like china those big
big economies that rely so heavily on
fossil fuels like coal that some of the
biggest polluters in the world now are
having to well i guess it's written in
within this text this draft text we need
to make that clear but it is the near
final agreement that it looks as though
they will need to make some quite strong
commitments on phasing these things out
unabated coal power of course
means coal that isn't a carbon that's
not being offset so it looks as though
at the moment that that remains in but
as i say dropping within the last few
seconds we have heard from alex sharma's
um special advisor this morning as well
yeah we have a rather cryptic uh tweet
from alex sharma the uk cop president's
advisor saying is that the sun rising on
a cop 26 outcome
big day fingers crossed emoji two how
much we can read into that remains to be
seen but a lovely picture of glass let's
see
hannah thomas peter is with us um hi
hannah what's your interpretation
okay so we're just hammering
it's been cracking through the textbook
yes just literally dropped just top of
the app okay so what i noticed the first
thing that everyone goes to is to try
and find this fossil fuel language is
it's still in the text yes it is and
it's unchanged now that's a surprise
because the brits and america
were saying
really clearly all the way through
it's it's not going to survive these
negotiations it was almost a sacrificial
lamb it had been it had been put up in
the text in order for other big
polluters to fight to take it out so
that they might agree to other things
okay but it's survived the nighttime
negotiations that's really significant
optically in particular i think john
kerry is your interpretation of that
because we're just hearing from ashna
that you said people like saudi arabia
or australia wanted it to be taken out
why they why were they so desperate to
get rid of it well because it specified
the
the ending of
unabated coal use and inefficient fossil
fuel subsidies and it wasn't so much
about the precise wording but just
crossing a threshold of actually having
a mention of fossil fuels in a cop text
this is the first time it's ever
happened as mad as that sounds
that's why it's so precedent setting and
that is why the uk and the us and others
who've got ambitious carbon reduction
targets will see that as a huge win if
it stays because this might not be the
final version just looking at other
things that that remained
there has been no change to the language
around adaptation finance
so obviously there's been an agreement
that's the amount of money available for
poorer countries to adapt to the changes
that are already happening so just to
clarify that it was a hundred billion
dollars a year they were supposed to be
reaching that by 2021 then they said it
would get to 2023 then maybe 2026 where
are we with that so
that's there the 100 billion is there
it's it is going to get there by 2023.
uh the poorer countries have been very
cross about it think of it as a betrayal
but there's nothing that can you know
that i don't think that countries are
going to get there any sooner than 2022
2023 and that actually hasn't been on
the table the adaptation piece of that
hundred billion this is all very
technical but actually to poorer nations
it really matters
is how much of that hundred billion and
whatever else the rest of the world
provides how much of that is available
for things like moving communities away
from rising sea levels better protecting
critical infrastructure nothing to do
with reducing carbon emissions but
keeping people and economies safe and
it's the countries that have the least
to spend on that stuff and at least to
cause the climate crisis who have been
so desperate for the proper amounts of
funding to keep themselves safe and not
only to survive but to thrive so
that adaptation language is still there
it calls on developed nations to at
least double the adaptation finance
the next bit and this is the other
really critical bit that the uk in
particular was really fighting to keep
is that it calls on all countries who
have signed the paris agreement to come
back with more ambitious carbon
reduction targets by the end of next
year
that's much sooner than 2025 which was
the previous agreement now it's that bit
of the whole text that the uk and others
believe will close the gap between what
has been promised and what is necessary
to keep 1.5 within reach which is the
overarching aim of this whole summit so
that's also a big win so the two big
questions are is it something that will
get over the line will all signs agree
to it and if so is it enough to keep 1.5
alive
simon steele who is the climate minister
for grenada and a central voice at cop
he's been in all the rooms he stood next
to barack obama when they did their
photo photo op you know because kind of
central figure
told me yesterday that this text as it
stands
is just about enough to keep 1.5 within
reach if it's weakened any further he
said
it won't be but it's like right on the
line it's bare minimum he said so my
interpretation having just seen the text
is that it is the same if not slightly
stronger as it was
yesterday and therefore cop will be able
to say if this text survives through the
next 12 hours or so that 1.5 has been
kept within reach the other thing to say
that was causing real trouble in
negotiating rooms yesterday was the loss
and damage piece of this which is a
separate bit
of you know of funding and that is that
poorer nations have said for a long time
that
they deserve repayment for
climate disasters uh that the loss and
damage that they have suffered
historically as a result of a climate
crisis that they did not cause
needs to be addressed now america in
particular has been very resistant to
being on the hook for an open-ended
amount of money
but poorer nations have said
it's central to to our agreement here we
will not
give you our agreement we'll withhold it
if you don't address loss and damage now
what hasn't happened in this text is
there's a kind of grand plan to start
shelling out cash to small or vulnerable
nations who've been really hit hard by
hurricanes
but it's opened the door
to further discussions which is all
those nations were asking for okay
ladies my goodness it's literally just
dropped properly put you on the spot and
of course you delivered with aplomb
we'll speak to you both again very
shortly thank you very much indeed
thanks a lot